whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are some
nanny wants to ban it presenting the
nanny of the month runners-up British
Prime Minister David Cameron is pushing
attacks on fatty foods after seeing the
Danes passive fat tax it's a way to show
people this is a good way to look
officials in Australia's Northern
Territory who are banning drinkers who
have had run-ins with the law from
buying grog her ideas quickly scans if
you're not bad and purchases night
supporters say the law has decreased
crime the critics say it's fuel to black
market if we can identify our person
who's supplying alcohol to people who
are on the band ring the register yes
what they go on the been drinkin
register themselves but there can be
only one any of the month and this time
it's the European Union where officials
have issued a slew of new regulations
targeting stuff kids like loads of fun
they lock she tell us do let's all sing
a song about balloons there shall be no
blowing up balloons for unsupervised
tots under age 8 and no whistleblowers
for those under 14 official site fears
about choking and germs when it comes to
teddy bears which must be machine
washable and easy with those aratus the
EU has slapped them with noise
restrictions check back next month for
more examples of busybodies minding your
own business